j'ai pas me prendre avec les gens
il ya une chose que je sais faire
[Musique]
c'est la mission était de découvrir ce
qu'ils savaient mais ce sera difficile
maintenant que vous les avez tous tués
je crois pas que vous êtes fait pour le
renseignement c'est votre dernière
chance à l'école au monde y ait pas de
la confiture partout dans le visage tout
le set 6 grata c'est trop tard pour
faire l'école à la maison et que vous
des blessés à les commenter en travaux
et le film on était en streaming
si kim apprend qu'une fille de 9 ans
nous a découvert ma carrière mais qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire
battus et simule un accident
peut-être les escaliers waouh film
encore on fait un marché clé qui montre
est une espionne qu'on s'entende bien
c'est exceptionnel après c'est fini à
digérer parce qu'on commence si les
parcours d'obstacles en commun voire la
cool pendant l'explosion boli grave je
peux sentir les mensonges les odeurs
fils ont une odeur et au mensonge chez
lui au moindre battement de cils comme
ça j'en déduis zamir tout et à tout âge
jeudi je suis persuadé qu'à jamais plus
à des stéroïdes
hu tout à l'heure quand tu regardes la
barre qui tu vas 90 civils dans un
périmètre mal sécurisés là-dedans
souriant qui salissent et s est traduit
bien
[Musique]
ah bon tour
l'objectif de cet exercice est d'arriver
à me contourner
je dirais que le meilleur moyen serait
causé une distraction sinon tu seras
jamais capables les pertes de 10
il est gentil
[Musique]
mikit qu'ils portent
on dirait la scène du mariage la fin des
chèques